[Music]  cubot Oh what's this ah this is London  it's wonderful  Oh Lucy always dreamed of coming to  London he saw this it would be like she  were finally here Oh Paddington  this is perfect I've had a brilliant  idea I'm going to get a job and buy that  book rod Lucy's birthday no window  cleaner are you quite sure you're ready  for the workplace Paddington Swedish  Buchanan dad celebrity clients  I suppose you know Dwyer oh yes you're a  very famous actor VIP celebrity or used  to be now you do dog food commercials  [Music]  mr. Gruber's antique shop but I'm not  the reef mysterious things have been  happening all over town well rich again  I may look like a hardened criminal but  I'm innocent we're gonna need a fool if  anyone connected by is a criminal sauce  the master of disguise well this is  great container turret haven't broken  anything  wouldn't hesitate if any of us needed  help he looks for the good in all of it  momily  take a seat  [Music]  [Music]